this office is dusty it's an older
office it's it's definitely old uh i
should stop wearing black shirts okay
what's going on guys this is rob it's
five o'clock in the morning i have not
had coffee yet i wouldn't say i'm
running on fumes but i would say that i
am still waking up so first things first
this video is going to have spoilers
and the second thing thank you guys i
misspoke yesterday in the video that i
made i meant to say the spell that was
cast at the end of the movie made the
world forget about peter parker in
general right that you know who peter
parker is at all instead i think i said
that the spell was like the completed
version of the original spell which is
the world forgot that peter parker was
spider-man uh regardless thank you guys
for correcting me on that yes the spell
that was cast at the end of the movie
basically removed the world's knowledge
of peter parker
period no one knows who peter parker is
right no one's ever heard of this guy
and anybody he meets he will have
basically been meeting for the very
first time right it's why happy hogan
doesn't know who peter parker is that's
why mj and ned leeds don't know who
peter parker is and so this is a really
really important thing because in the
world of comics we call this a soft
reboot this is not new marvel comics
does this all the time in fact that's
what the original one more day one
moment in time and brand new days story
lines were they were basically a soft
reboot of spider-man right that this guy
joke assad had come in as
editor-in-chief of marvel comics in the
aftermath of like their near bankruptcy
in the 1990s and he was like clean slate
spider-man he didn't like the idea of
spider-man being married to mary jane
watson and stuff like that he felt like
it aged him it didn't keep him like
eternally youthful which is kind of what
you need if you're going to be able to
sell spider-man comics for any real
length of time otherwise people will
expect him to just kind of age out of
the role and then eventually leave and
so you got basically one more day which
got rid of the marriage between peter
parker and mary jane watson and then you
got one moment in time and brand new day
that was designed to remove the world's
knowledge that peter parker was
spider-man of course the world knew that
because in the comics peter parker had
revealed his identity publicly during
this civil war storyline as a display
that he trusted iron man in his
statement about superhuman registration
and all that kind of stuff and so again
it's a soft reboot right that basically
it kind of restructures and reworks the
character in such a way to where they
are basically starting over and in fact
that's what we were told in the movie
that when the spell goes through right
when the spell happens and and basically
the world forgets that peter parker
exists peter parker is going to have to
start over he's going to be starting
from scratch and that's really kind of
the nature of the ending of this film is
that peter parker becomes the spider-man
that we always expect him to be the
spider-man that we know you guys have
probably noticed over the course of
homecoming and far from home and even to
a degree the beginning of this movie
that peter parker
wasn't really spider-man right the tom
holland wasn't really the peter parker
that we know from either the comics or
just the films or a combination of both
right the peter parker's usually broke
but peter parker sells pictures to the
daily bugle and makes just enough money
to live right he's surviving paycheck to
paycheck not really even living paycheck
to paycheck right just surviving right
uh that's the nature of peter parker
it's called the parker luck that things
just don't work out for him right the
thing is just that any time things could
take an upward trend and his life could
get better
something happens it just stops it from
happening though the parker looks kind
of just an on running joke right so like
if you guys remember the old toby
mcguire movies when he was like yeah man
like i've got this date i'm gonna go
i've got flowers and everything i'm
gonna go see like mary jane watson or
something and then like harry osborne
comes swooping in and like attacks him
you know in spider-man 3. uh that's an
example right that's the parker luck
right just anything bad that can happen
will happen
and so it's one of those one of those
kind of hallmarks of his character the
fact that he's broke the fact that
things just don't really seem to work
out in his favor and tom holland has
officially become that spider-man now
right he's going to take his ged now
there are a couple possibilities on what
you could see here a really good
possibility is the introduction of the
fantastic four not in so far is this on
his face right like you know johnny
storm writing a giant four in the sky
peter parker's like wow i want to be a
part of that team no what i could see
happening is that we know peter parker
is taking his ged if he hasn't already
done it so likely when he gets into his
apartment he's got like a stack of books
and one of them is the ged and so it
looks like he's getting ready to take it
right he's going to study for he's going
to take it we know he's going to crush
it the guy was going to be accepted into
mit right i mean
we know he's going to crush
a ged test but i wouldn't be surprised
if whether it's because he crushed that
test or because he applied to maybe
various colleges or what have you and
his his intelligence was just tested off
the charts that he gets an invitation to
join the future foundation and that's
the extent of it right that's that's all
you get right he just he is like he's
going through his mail and there's a an
envelope that he throws on the table and
you're cordially invited to join the
future foundation and that's it why does
that matter because the future
foundation was a think tank of the
world's smartest young people created by
reed richards of the fantastic four so
while it may not necessarily be that
reed is like officially mr fantastic and
like susan storm is the invisible woman
and ben grimm has become the thing and
johnny storm is you know johnny storm
while that may not have happened yet
right the trip into space in the cosmic
race that reed richards does exist in
the marvel cinematic universe and he's
noticed peter parker again it'd be a
small little cameo thing that's the kind
of stuff that you could see if i'm being
honest with you guys what i think will
happen over the course of the future of
the mcu is that we know with the new
trilogy coming
it can kind of go a couple different
ways we know that for example that sony
is building up the sinister six right
now things are a little murky i mean we
kind of got the sinister six in the
movie but not really they weren't really
the sinister six i mean they were in
name only but in terms of like the role
they played what made this sinister six
the sinister six is that they were a
group that was brought together by dr
octopus for the sole purpose of
destroying spider-man right that each
one of them had been defeated by
spider-man over their time as a criminal
and that unifying their efforts and
trying to kill spider-man was the best
chance they had of pulling it off and
spider-man no way home this really more
the sinister six by circumstance right
it's not really the centers for six it's
just six villains who happen to be in
the same place that's really all it is
right now it's nothing sinister about it
i mean maybe the sinister three is the
closest you get right like electro and
sandman in lizard and then like the
sinister fourth kind of but not really
who showed up at the last minute right
at the 11th hour which is the green
goblin you know when he comes swooping
in like at the very end of the battle
and destroys the box that's holding the
spell so it's not really sinister six
but we know that sony's working on
sinister six more so than that sony's
developing villains we know that there's
like michael morbius right we know that
like venom kind of seems to exist out
there but now we've basically confirmed
venom is in his own universe right like
tom hardy venom is out there doing his
own thing and a universe that's totally
separate from the mcu but michael
morbius showed up and you've also got
like michael keaton who is in the
trailer so presumably michael morbius is
in the marvel cinematic universe as well
and then there's whatever else happens
to come out of that right we know that
they're working on like a crave in the
hunter film and things along those lines
so this direction for the future of
spider-man in the marvel cinematic
universe could go a couple different
ways maybe they kill him off he's killed
by the sinister six like he was in the
ultimate universe maybe he retires we'll
make a video on that uh in in the future
right where we think the actual series
is going in the new trilogy because i've
got a few ideas and i think one of them
is the most plausible idea i think it's
a really really good idea all we really
know right now is that feige at least
according to movie web in an interview
that he did recently about lisa was
posted like 11 hours ago is he's like
we're definitely working on spider-man
4. i think they made that determination
i think they were a little iffy they
were a little unsure because the way the
movie ends they could just stop they
could just be like okay like we're done
with tom hall and spider-man though like
i said right like we'll have like
spider-man right you'll see spider-man
in future movies but like you won't see
him as tom holland or something like
that or they're like we're done with
solo movies and like that's basically it
and then like the only time you ever see
tom holland again is something that kind
of like iron man when you just see him
in other movies right like after iron
man 3 you never got a solo iron man film
again but he appeared in like infinity
war civil war avengers in-game things
like that and maybe they you know they
could just do that with spider-man such
as it is feige was like nah man
we're gonna make a lot of money here so
we're definitely doing a spider-man 4
and we would be foolish not to ask for
it right i mean we want more spider-man
movies especially now when you look at
the fact that like tom holland s
spider-man was basically spoiled over
his entire tenure right everything was
just given to him tony stark's just like
here's everything you need to become an
effective spider-man and he didn't
really understand the lesson that with
great power must come great
responsibility until aunt may died the
fact that his actions have consequences
and what he did basically got aunt may
killed the green goblin wasn't lying
when he said that when it really said i
may have been the one that dealt the
killing blow to on me but you're the one
who put her in this situation in the
first place if it hadn't been for you i
wouldn't be here she wouldn't be dead
and that's an accurate statement right
it's not him messing with peter parker
that's the god's honest truth
and so that was really kind of peter
realizing i'm the one who got my aunt
may killed and him kind of becoming
spider-man right the the character that
we all know and love that we expect him
to be and so when you look at like the
three movies right it's just kind of an
origin story for his character the
question now is
what are we going to see in this new
trilogy the one thing i will say about
this idea that i have i think at the end
of this next trilogy right so i guess
like spider-man 6 they're going to kill
him they're going to kill off tom
holland you know another question that
has to be asked here is are we going to
see like mj and jacob babylon again the
nature of their characters and the way
they were written we could never see
them again and that would be it right
again we kind of have some ideas on
what's going to happen with them and
we'll talk about them in future videos
but there's a lot of cool things i think
that the way this movie ended in terms
of like toby mcguire and andrew garfield
i think they're setting the stage for
future appearances in marvel cinematic
universe projects specifically secret
wars or spider-verse right we know that
like beyond spider versus coming out the
new spider-verse movie where they gave
us a little bit of a teaser where like
basically miles morales the animated
version met like miguel o'hara
spider-man 2099 we know that kind of
thing what's going on so we know they're
building up the concept of the
spider-verse i wouldn't be surprised if
at a future point in time you end up
seeing some kind of massive crossover
event between what's basically the end
of the spider-verse cast and like toad
maguire andrew garfield and tom holland
i wouldn't be surprised if that was the
case and i think it'd be great if it was
you know having this kind of giant
spider-verse brought together for the
purpose of uniting all these different
spiderman i think this was kind of a
taste right because if you notice it
kind of happened on both sides right
into the spider verse was animated miles
meeting like spider-gwen and spider-ham
and spider-man noir and all those
different versions of peter parker but
then when you look at like spider-man no
way home it's tom holland meeting toby
mcguire and andrew garfield it's
basically the same thing right like two
teams of spider-man coming together to
face off against a singular threat with
that singular threat basically being a
very humanized threat right something
along those lines it's kind of cool to
see i'm excited about the idea the
prospect of what may come with all this
stuff because then it's very easy to
unite those two things together and then
you've got animated miles and animated
gwen and animated uh you know spider-man
noir teaming up with like andrew
garfield which would be kind of weird to
see andrew garfield knocking on like
animated spider-gwen but then like tom
holland and toby mcguire and that kind
of a thing i think it'd be great it'd be
a great concept but let me know what you
guys think down in the comments section
let me know if you guys are really if
you guys think this is all kind of
leading up right like the ending of this
film the fact that like andrew garfield
and toby maguire were left alive as
opposed to being killed off the fact
that it's like we'll see you around like
let me know if you guys think that's
leading into like a future spider-verse
event where like all these characters
are going to come back for a huge
crossover storyline let me know you guys
think down in the comments section thank
you guys for watching and i will catch
you all later
peace